two people went to the same university
had the same classes
but some will have a lot of
opportunities after some will have none
because
this one has a huge network the other
one has no network
so it's the network it's the exposure
it the the thing that you do in parallel
and how you develop your yourself what
things you learn
what things you learn what they sell
soft skills you develop during all this
time so
how how you develop your entrepreneurial
mindset so we're working a lot with two
data engineers how they are developing
their entrepreneurial mindset even
though they not everyone will end up
being an entrepreneur
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i'm
going to be talking to rabia zayud an
entrepreneur lecturer and community
leader
zayud started his first business when he
was 20 years old and has since been
involved in the israeli startup
ecosystem he has served as the vice
president for the mena region at voice
it
was the mass challenge finalist in 2014
and he co-founded hasoub a non-profit
grassroots movement that turns to be one
of the leading organizations that
promotes taking entrepreneurship in arab
society he is currently the ceo of
hassou
[Applause]
[Music]
this show really is about why do people
do what they do and and um
every once in a while i meet somebody
who's literally working on something
that is so life changing and impactful
not just for for people but for a
community of people and
and i can't help but but put you in that
in that classification because of the
incredible work that you're doing with
khasub and you're looking at the
grassroots movement looking at the arab
tech entrepreneurs and the ecosystem
really really inspiring work having been
following it for years myself but but
i'm hopeful that in these 20 minutes
we're able to shine a little bit of
light into your own journey what do you
care about what excites you what
motivates you and what you've done until
now with khasub and the and the vision
that you have for the future of of this
sector so again rabia thank you very
very much for being here
thank you so much and happy beauty to be
here and to share write a bit about why
i'm doing what i'm doing and we are
doing what we are doing today i'm not
alone so i'm part of a bigger group
and why it's important and it's so
important
awesome well rabia take me away for a
second back to your own upbringing where
where do you grow up how how does this
issue even become top of mind for you
so i born and raised in safar i am an
oldest brother of five siblings uh
for
an amazing mom and dad who had who
didn't have the chance
to complete their high studies so they
drop off like in high school
and even before i think uh and they
invested in us in in
in us so much and they said okay we
didn't have the chance so you are going
to have this chance and you are going to
the academia and to to learn and to
build a better future for yourself
so
and things started
i i like i have a lecture that i always
give about sipping out of your comfort
zone so i remember stepping out of my
comfort zone when i was a kid a very
little kid when i went to play football
in mathabe fifa
so i used to be a midfielder
and then
and then it was i was the only arab
there i was the only arab in the team i
remember myself and then
okay
today you can tell that i'm not a
successful
football player but this stepping out of
my comfort zone while being a kid teach
me a lot of how to go out and to explore
and push your talent to the boundaries
so in high school i went to study
in haifa i was in i told you i bought
the bournemouth armor so i started
taking the ball
more than one hour uh two hours a day
just to go and wow
diet schools in haifa and also this
experience kind of experiencing the
university when you are in high school
traveling every day meeting people from
all around the country it was a very
unique school in haifa called the arab
orthodox college and
uh
when i finished when i finished high
school
i from one hand i had like i told you we
are five siblings so i have my
my youngest siblings amalan ahmad they
born with um
with cerebral palsy
so
i had a lot
of connection to do something for them
and do something for people with
disabilities so i started thinking about
how can i
learn study something that work with
people with disabilities so
but perhaps or after high school i
registered to study physical therapy but
from the other ma like from the other
hand
i had a lot of fashion to business and
to do things like to not business but to
start thinking to fix things so
i saw that there's a lot of pupils
that coming from tough background stuff
like economic and social background who
cannot
bridge the gaps that they have in their
school in their classes so i i built
like you know i was 20 i started my
first business it was called our future
uh most of balna in arabic and
so i can give a platform for
pupils who don't have the sport at all
to get the support from uh you know
teachers after school hours so they can
have someone to help them with their
with their classes
then at the same universe the same year
i started to study physical therapy at
tel aviv university and then
while being there like studying physical
therapy and running a business
the year after i started the i saw like
i had a i had scholarship
and
i had to like to spend 60 hours
volunteering uh in some place so i went
through the places and they say i saw
their tel aviv university
entrepreneurship center i said okay
perfect
interesting it so it was yeah the mood
like the word entrepreneurship was so
uh
something like that i didn't know
so your whole journey for
entrepreneurship actually started
because of the volunteering that you
needed to do for your physio physical
therapist scholarship to tel aviv
university exactly exactly so pretty
cool so yeah so i went there
and i remember uh like i went to this
entrepreneurship center like to meet
with the ceo or in cemanian
you will get out for here with something
trust me
and i really liked it like i really
start liking the what the the vibes
there the things that will be done and
often like you know like you get going
to into a place and open like a whole
new world for you so i didn't know
nothing about all these
startups fundraising exit all these kind
of things and like it's happening here
like it's one hour away from where i
where i used to live
and
i don't know nothing about it i know a
lot of talented people that i know know
nothing about it
and every so i started going to a
lobster event and started to organize
some event
and every time i went there i i was the
only arab in the room so
a year after i got accepted to a
fellowship uh
about economic empowerment through
entrepreneurship in michigan university
in
michigan and i spent one month there
with people from all the mena region
and also i met there an amazing
entrepreneur called danny weisberg
he used to like he was developing he in
the first days of developing his startup
called voice it a voice to voice
translation
it was the ver the first voice to voice
translation uh uh solution for people
with disability so after coming back
from the state he invited me over to
come and work with him a little bit on
his startup and then
i joined the startup as like
in the department of the business
development a year after we got accepted
to mass challenge boston so i worked a
lot with the with the with the voice it
on many aspects in the business
developments like a conferences
collaborations partnerships with schools
with companies with different
stakeholders and then in mass challenge
i worked also with fundraising and many
many components and and still all this
was there was a student like in tel aviv
university it's what between you know
while studying so doing all this thing
and then
the highlight was when i was
when i had to pitch the company in the
wall street journal conference in l.a
and
danny also like in the same day we had
two conflicted so danny went to our
conference i went to another conference
and we won in this conference that i
went to to the worst to journal we won
like a first place and there was a huge
huge like vr on the wall street journal
and a lot of buzz
so coming back from
this experience in the states in in
boston and then in l.a and like coming
back to tel aviv and
i was about to finish my my degree
but i couldn't help like seeing
all the amazing things happening around
me in the ecosystem in tel aviv and also
the experience that they have abroad
and looking about the community i'm
coming from i say okay like we are 21 in
this uh in the country but we each time
i go to a place i'm the only arab in the
room and looking at the numbers we are
telling today like 2022 where maybe
2.5 in the ecosystem i think
i'm sure that we have much much more
potential to be
to fulfill in the in the height again
entrepreneurship ecosystem but the fact
that many people are not aware
sure many many people are not connected
to the right places they didn't have
someone direct them to the place where
they care where they can prosper and
fulfill their potential so
we so coming back from boston i
connected with a friend hassan abushan
and taught hassan like i want to bring
back what i used to do in tel aviv
university he said rabia i'm just
starting doing something in my basement
so i connected with hassan the we
started like this draft movement that
turned out to has later on
with some
another amazing guys who we used to work
in google and after and all these
heightened companies to everyone just
came so 2014 was like weekly basis we
met on weekly basis on hassan's place
and then 2015 we went out and we
registered the company and uh sorry a
non-profit and we started doing events
all over the country like from arabi
what happened
from those weekly meetups in the garage
how what happened in those meetings that
led you to want to then sort of register
this as a non-profit or or as a more
comprehensive organization that you're
actually going to be dedicating a lot of
time to what was going on there okay so
what
was going on is we saw that
there's a huge need for this just this
platform we didn't have like a
curriculum that we were like giving
there or something it just was the
platform people brought up their laptop
their laptop
one one table just did like a wanted to
learn how to develop an android another
table did like ios web uh design so it
was and every time we started to host
like someone to give a lecture about a
a a specific topic so it was a community
that started up and people people could
do the same thing just sitting home but
they want a place where people sharing
the same passion the same things sitting
together it helps them keeping this
because
one of the if you go to arab cities in
arab villages you don't have these
meetups on weekly basis or something
that you can go in the evening and have
like a lecture or something there's a
huge huge gap and left these things so
having this thing on a weekly basis just
gather people so we had people from high
school
and people like engineers senior
engineers coming sitting in the same
room and all the people felt that they
are belong to this place and they want
to share and they want to be
more productive so this is what's the
motive how to be more productive
in that in the technological world and
not only as a consumers
so more and more and more people feel
that they want to be part of this
and i'm telling you it was saturdays
people like some people their parents
drove them all the way to spend the day
there wow so
when we saw all this huge need for such
a platform
we went a year after and we registered
as a nonprofit but also like we did it
like there was there wasn't a huge
strategy
so we were only also like all or our
students are busy with our different
like work that we did there in parallel
and
uh we kept doing things we kept doing a
lot of things and then we started doing
all these meetups in universities in
arab cities and villages
uh participating in different
conferences with as a community and
hackathons so
we kept doing all this in volunteering
were
for four years like from 2014 to 2017
there was a moment in 2017 that we said
okay enough like it can't be it can't
it can't be
like going bigger and bigger without
anyone taking a responsibility and
taking the lead likes to and moving and
handling all this responsibility because
it became a huge responsibility
interesting so
by the way just just focusing on this
responsibility aspect well how do you
how do you articulate that
responsibility what was your
responsibility organizing this thing
the responsibility was that
people
felt like that they want to learn more
they want come to us come to our city
come to our village we want like every
time that we organize something it was a
full house and when you organize again
and again think and there's always a
full house
you understand that there's something
here and
and when we when we sit like i remember
this meeting with the team with the core
team of volunteers that came in in late
2017 and we said guys we cannot run all
these activities on a volunteering base
because it deserves like i remember
myself working like eight nine hours in
my job and another eight nine hours in
hatu like it was crazy years that you're
like you're doing both as a full-time
job and
then we arrive to a point that said okay
either we keep it very small
and like to do like two to three events
a year very small
awareness based like let's do awareness
let's do like some
lecture here lecture there maybe i want
one friends a year and that's it
or we really take it
seriously and someone will jump and
do the work as it should be and start
building an organization here and i
remember me taking taking the lead uh
when we're going to the states raising
doing start like establishing all the
foundations for an organization world of
directors
strategy doing fundraising
all the other things that uh
most of the people are hearing us like
and leaving something know about so
today fast forward 2022 we are six
people in the organization and growing
uh went from like zero budget to
managing like few millions in budget
every year in activities and
in like also activities that
ranging from raising awareness to giving
skills to their network because in many
cases the arabs community was our
society was isolated like i i don't know
if you had like arab colleague going to
university with you and you see them
like usually our students going to go to
university do they was they would keep
like closed and with their friends
so going out of university they will
still have the same friends they didn't
have the network so we are working a lot
on networking because by the end of the
day
it's the people that you know
like
two people went to the same university
have the same classes
but some will have a lot of
opportunities after some will have none
because
this one has a huge network the other
one has no network so it's the network
it's the exposure it the the thing that
you do in parallel and how you develop
your yourself what things you learn what
things you learn what they sell
soft skills you develop during all this
time so
how how you develop your entrepreneurial
mindset so we're working a lot with two
detailed engineers how they are
developing their entrepreneurial mindset
even though they not everyone will end
up being an entrepreneur but we believe
that as a student and as an a
professional if you develop an
entrepreneurial mindset
you will be a different you would be a
different person you will be a different
employee you will approach seeing it's
different for everybody right yeah it's
terrific for everybody and
today so today the scope of hasov is
even much bigger so we are focusing in
three main area
the first area is as i mentioned
fulfilling the potential of the arab
entrepreneurship talent into high tech
and entrepreneurship so we were working
with students engineers entrepreneurs
and also a the whole thing with
infrastructure so we are having
our first flagship project in this place
we took an old building in arara a very
very historical of all buildings was
about abandoned in the last 20 years we
approached the municipality we took the
building and we had a huge renovation
for this building to turn it into the
first innovation center uh uh
for the arab society in an arab city in
arab so it's going to be reading
very soon we are having the
the official grand opening in
september 16th with our fifth annual
conference uh
listeners you are invited uh
and also the third thing that we do
is we train arab business people and
high-tech executives and professional to
become an angel investors so
we had already two cohorts of the arab
angels club we trained
40 people to become an arab and to
become an angel investors so far
our alumni invested around one million
dollar like in trades like that range
between twenty thousand dollars to one
hundred fifty thousand dollars uh
so if i want to wrap it up today hasubi
is an ecosystem builder
that works with talent
with
with fun with the angels and like
funders and also building the needed
infrastructure and
we don't believe that we
should stay separate isolated so we are
connecting all of this to the local
ecosystem and to the global ecosystem so
we are working closely with a lot of vcs
and entrepreneurs and all the
multinational companies uh that based in
tel aviv and haisan everywhere so
yeah
unbelievable and and i think that uh
you know 20 minutes is not nearly enough
time to to try and cover half of half of
what you're doing but but you can just
tell that this is your life that this is
sort of a mission that you're on
that that you need this to happen coming
from your own background your own sort
of this and i could hear when you were
talking about the discovery of
entrepreneurship and what that does to a
person i hear going back to sort of your
own discovery of entrepreneurship as a
moot in tel aviv university and how that
and how that experience that you that
you happen to to learn and you happen to
experience it now you're providing that
opportunity to many many others but not
just stopping there you're you're
bridging together
the gap between their own
entrepreneurial experience
and the way that the outside world
experiences that endeavor and and
collaborates with it and and gets inside
of it so hey rabia again amazing work
very very inspiring for myself and and i
hope that others listening here
had have some inspiration as well and i
really appreciate your time your effort
and your energy to this ecosystem and
and i can't wait to host you again and
tell more of your story so thank you
very very much robia
thank you thank you so much
thank you again for having me today and
happy happy to be here with you thank
you fantastic thank you rabia thank you